[ APPLAUSE ]
>> BACK TO NELSON.
REJECTED AND THAT GOES OUT OF
BOUNDS.
THEY'LL KEEP POSSESSION.
TO THE PAINT.
ASK AROUND.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
.
>> STRIPPED AWAY.
NELSON OUTSIDE.
BROWN, RIGHT SIDE.
DISHES IT TO NELSON.
YOU KNOW THEY WANTED THAT ONE TO
GO DOWN.
LET'S PROVE IT TIME.
FOURTH QUARTER.
DON'T GET IT DONE NOW.
NO MORE CHANCES.
HE'S HAVING QUITE THE QUARTER
CONVERTING AT A REALLY HIGH
PERCENTAGE AND SO OUT OF BOUNDS
IT GOES.
AND THEY'LL KEEP POSSESSION.
BROWN WITH THE BOUNCE PASS.
BLOCKED AGAIN.
PITCHED OVER BY BROWN.
>> THIS GUY HAS BEEN EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE ALL NIGHT.
THAT IQ HAS BEEN ON DISPLAY.
.
>> HE'S REALLY BEEN DOWN HERE
THROUGH THE STRETCH.
FIVE OF SEVEN THROUGH THE FIELD.
RIGHT WING.
ALWAYS GOING UP FOR THE
ALLEY-OOP HERE.
PASSES IT TO NELSON.
THEN BACK UP.
THERE'S THE STEEL AND THERE IS
THE WHISTLE.
THAT'S FOUL NUMBER TWO FOR HIM.
>> HE NEEDS TO GET HIMSELF UNDER
CONTROL.
THAT'S TWO FOULS IN LESS THAN 60
SECONDS.
PICKED HIS POCKET.
NELSON OUTSIDE.
PASS TO BROWN.
DOWN LOW.
OUT TO THE RIGHT WING.
AND THE DISH.
TO THE MIDDLE.
BOY, IN A CLOSE GAME.
IT IS NICE TO HAVE HIM ON HIS
SIDE.
CLOSE HERE TO GIVE HIM SOME
LIFE.
CAN YOU SEE THE EMPHASIS HERE IN
THE SECOND, A LOT MORE EFFORT TO
GET THE BALL TO THE OUTSIDE.
IT IS STARTING TO PAY DIVIDENDS.
EXCELLENT.
EXCELLENT BOX OUT THERE.
KEEPING HIMSELF BETWEEN THE MAN
AND THE BASKET.
INSIDE.
THE PASS TO BROWN.
NELSON OUTSIDE ON THE WING
BROWN.
PASSES IT TO NELSON.
OUT TO THE WING.
AND THERE'S THE ALLEY-OOP.
THAT'S NASTY.
TALK ABOUT THE ATHLETICISM ON
THAT THING.
HE FEEDS IT TO BROWN.
AND THERE IS THE PASS TO NELSON.
NOT SHY FROM OUTSIDE.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
SPREADING THE FLOOR AND GETTING
HIM UP.
TAKES IT TO NELSON.
ON TOP BROWN.
NELSON OUTSIDE.
OUT LEFT TO THE WING.
AND HE IS ONE COOL CUSTOMER,
GUYS.
ISN'T HE?
EVERY POSSESSION DOWN THE
STRETCH.
HE'S BEEN READY WITH ONLY ONE
MISS AGAINST HIS SIX MAKES.
TO THE INSIDE.
SENSATIONAL BLOCK.
>> REALLY STARTING TO ATTACK ON
THE INTERIOR.
SHOWING A MORE PHYSICAL PRESENCE
HERE ON THE SECOND HALF.
TONIGHT.
SNATCHED AWAY.
>> HE HAS NOT MISSED A SHOT IN
THIS ORDER.
THEY TRIED RUNNING DIFFERENT
THINGS IN HIM BUT HE'S BEEN
UNSTOPPABLE.
>> WELL NOT BEHIND BECAUSE OF
THIS GUY.
HE'S PUTTING ON A TREMENDOUS
RUN.
>> TO THE LEFT WING.
OUT LEFT TO THE WING.
THERE IS THE STEAL.
>> EASY CHANCE AT MIDRANGE.
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO SEE HIM
WIN THAT PLAY AGAIN.
IT IS JUST WHAT THE DOCTOR
ORDERED HERE AND WHAT THEY NEED
AGAIN IN THE QUARTER.
TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
AND CERTAINLY THEY ARE NOT
HESITATING LETTING IT FLY FROM
DEEP INSIDE HERE.
AND HE LOBS IT UP TOWARD THE
RIM.
>> AND HOW ABOUT THE PERFORMANCE
WE ARE SEEING FROM HIM.
NOT ONE MISS ON THE DAY.
>> IN CASE ANYONE WAS WONDERING,
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN
YOU ARE IN THE ZONE.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE ALL
QUARTER.
>> ON THE WING JACKSON.
RIDING THE HOT HAND AND WHY NOT?
IF SOMETHING IS WORKING, KEEP
GOING TO IT.
>> OUT TO THE RIGHT WING.
>> GUYS, I LIKE WHAT THEY ARE
DOING HERE IN THE SECOND HALF.
GETTING A LOT OF PRODUCTION IN
THE PAINT.
STILL TRAILING BUT STARTING TO
SHOW SOME GRIT DOWN LOW.
>> HE IS ONE COOL CUSTOMER.
HE'S BEEN READY WITH ONLY ONE
MISS AGAINST THIS SIX MAKES.
>> PASS TO HENRY.
YOU CAN JUST SEE THE CONFIDENCE
LEVEL GROWING WITH EACH SHOT
HE'S MADE.
NOW FIVE OF FIVE HERE IN THE
FOURTH.
ADDING TO THIS LEAD.
HE'S BEEN DEPENDABLE AND
CONSISTENT AT THE OFFENSIVE END.
>> PASS TO JACKSON.
>> HE HAS BEEN UNREAL HERE.
9 OF 10 IN THE FOURTH QUARTER.
I JUST DON'T KNOW IF THE GAME
CAN BE PLAYED ANY BETTER.
HE IS ON A MISSION.
THAT'S EIGHT OF NINE HERE.
>> THE PASS TO NEWTON.